ben tiens
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
matsuko cost au revoir s'était juré dax
connu ici à ou un ex connu à part
nathalie marqué par vous vous étiez avec
qui ah non moi j'ai pas d'ex connu c'est
vrai mais on est trop jeune vous vous
kenza du loft du loft
ah ouais ben a craqué pour lui c'est
vrai que kenza du matériel isabella
kenzo encore à l'autre oui j'en ai
encore un autre nom bah ouais ouais j'ai
pensé je vous dis casser la
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrêter quoi patrick fiori wallon avec
patrick bruel
oui patrick patrimoine ya longtemps mais
diarra sera à bbm n attendait que vous
êtes sortis et patrimoine oui mais genre
pendant combien de temps homme à peine
un mois
je suis parti aux antilles moi ouais
alors vous êtes amoureuse non parce que
je savais de toute façon ça ferait une
histoire courte armés c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement généreux extrêmement
intelligent c'est un amour
ah oui quand vous voyez ça il ya un
petit et bien on s'est revu il ya pas
longtemps dix ans et demi pendant les
vacances et yann l'année dernière et on
était sur le même club et
jean-pierre il était au courant et puis
cette fois-là petit jean pierre et puis
maintenant j'ai vu ses enfants et ouais
mais c'est quelqu'un de super pas très
bon franchement y en a un par jour il y
en a un ça va
on respecte at any 1 alors vous qui
alors c'est vrai que tient bernard oui
l'idée de nier elle jouait dehors
j'étais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est elle était l'héroïne d'une
série et est reçu en france à l'aide
américaine française allait me dis
comment l'idée des idées elle est très
bien à paris 13ème pas on a vécu
ensemble
non on est resté votre marché sympa les
gens du palais repartir le seul ps elle
prenait pas des autographes tous les
journaux on va la toucher 40 côté en mai
c'est à l'époque la série passe et
beauté et dans ce cas là vous voulez
sortir avec un héros de série jo vous
auriez dû sortir ses bijoux
c'est vrai maxime adéquat sorti à la
sortie j'ai eu un coup de coeur du
design célibat mais j'ai visé haut et
j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour
l'animatrice ti gars qui présentait
chapelle alors ouais on s'est connu à
l'époque sur w9 on s'était vus dans une
soirée la lorraine avec elle le principe
de pécho servir messi projet les invités
à une soirée au départ
ensuite je les ai invités au restaurant
c'était vous l appel porté à new york
faire une wii
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et donc mais entre temps on s'est revus
ouais on a mis les mecs à sortent avec
des chroniqueurs à ce bar aux états unis
après veulent pouvoir il a de suite à la
ga et fatigue au plus tôt angers sco
elle vous met tous d'accord jordan
hassiba explique michael jordan mais non
on en avait déjà parlé mais oui ils ont
bien supporté qu'on me sentais mal
ascenseur s'est ouvert hier que la
première pour une fois c'est qui le mit
la main au panier
[Rires]
non on rappelle aux téléspectateurs vous
êtes sortie de my tho j'entends oui mais
c'était pas ça me rend malade marester
tulle à quoi s'est jamais eu d'aventuré
'qui ne valait plus que maxime avec tag
alors de se tenir lieu de balade des
galoches vous avez couché en fin de
compte et si je fais ici il ya eu oui
oui à la vie baleines sont gratuits
en vérité non non ça qui n'est pas nous
regardent pas raconte la vie d'un air
jordan une chaussure 56 savent aussi
vous dire le reste l'écran fait une très
belle émission
alors oui oui oui quoi oui oui et non
non mais sinon bah oui alors si oui tu
souris
bah oui sourit malgré la prescription
merci avocat
tout